vi ricordate ragazzi per caso emili
wants to play io sì non so perché me lo
ricordo ma a me lo ricordo è uscito il 2
o meglio la demo del 2 quelle belle
notizie che ti rallegrano la giornata
l'ho scaricata la demo pesa 2 giga quasi
una temo che pesa 2 giga va bene o hanno
racchiuso il demonio in questo gioco che
pesa così tanto non lo so però vabbè
giochiamo bene quando uscire altre
facciamo emily va dal dentista che
secondo me utile prezzo intero out entro
un gioco luminoso direi the plaza crisi
pardi è ovvio che brutta ombra su un
pelato anno cielo cappello bene e va
bene c'è un minimo di trame bei quadri
dei quadri di quindi sono tornato che
schifo da un party che era po dentro
perché dovrei andarmene è perché si
stupido o sonno è mai dormire di york io
io non giocherei a starò cos'è la
psicologia della reazione
per adesso è fatto benissimo mi piace un
sacco l'ordine nei videogiochi americani
proprio inesistente ma neanche per
sbaglio ci sono riuscito a farmi a
spaventarmi da solo successo disattivato
riattivato la corrente style.it ue un
jump square da solo un genio
però io che ho pensato qualcosa si è
evidentemente visto che è più ordinata
una discarica
devo andare al tiro di sopra per andare
a dormire si però è buio quindi non so
quanta voglia ci possa mai andare di
porto la teiera se potevo veramente
prenderlo ero troppo contento [ __ ]
tua sorella morta in salamoia in
putrefazione ti pare ti pare primo e ha
dovuto far saltare dalla sedia al
secondo si apre
aveva un giovane fattorino è morto
perché camminava nella sua casa senza la
torcia faccina i quasi 2 gb di peso per
cosa sono scusami che il peso della
grandezza delle mie palle dopo aver
giocato suo gioco
vabbè se la flashlight non me la dai non
fare il sapientone perché non c'era la
flashlight damista torcia una dizione
dove dovrebbe essere porca vacca non ho
idea di dove sia la torcia in it goes up
stairs made a ok al buio al buio queste
mi fido fa tasse salve dove dove un
delle forbici vi ammazzo le famiglie vi
ammazzo tutti sono le sei del mattino
tra l'altro ho il mio letto dormo con le
forbici perché sono una persona
tagliente
e successo ma se erano le sei come farne
sale 3d nostri che hai dormito per 18
ore
o ancora le mie forbici si fermi grazie
stupido allarme
vabbè delle chiavi perfetto ho bisogno
di una doccia prima di andare al lavoro
ma come andare a lavoro e cerchi prima
sto tizio salve tizio che vuole andare
al lavoro c'è un cadavere nel tuo
armadio frega niente frega niente voce
la torcia qualche bello d'asma
flashlight finalmente vedo 4 e
pomeriggio
seguici dei liberi va bene la porta si è
chiusa da sola e la lasciamo così non è
un problema doccia belli sti collage ok
perfetto
molto meglio io vi faccio la doccia con
la torcia è un problema l'acqua è verde
quindi o sono hulk o c'è un problema di
fondo qua va bene la casa in disordine e
uno schifo o un cadavere nell'armadio la
vasca e verde però vabbè facciamoci la
doccia stai orgasm andò ti sei lavando
spiegazioni adesso la pasqua ancora più
verde di prima devo andare a lavare i
piatti prima di andare va bene
che schifo ragazzi mettere in ordine a
casa tua gesù tutto bene tu li prego di
sì
ma perché continui ad inciampare sulle
cose maledizione non c'è più
non c'è più il tizio churchill disse
nell'armadio ma lui va tranquillo in
giro per casa va bene va bene e non
facciamo domande andiamo avanti le mie
amiche forbici mi servirebbero in questo
momento però vabbè
[Musica]
no grazie
sì grazie i piatti sono di qua e 60 per
cortesia
ecco bravo grazie molto gentile che è
successo
smettila gli orgasmi arechi hecker
gassman aiuto una katana perfetto me la
posso portare in giro ti prego dimmi di
sì che affetto tutti ci sei cagato
addosso è con la mia katana abbia
sbattuto fuori dalla mano servizio
questa è casa mia
cav h è riuscito a sbattermi fuori dalla
porta di casa mia
questo era uno dei temi di once play
quello vecchio
grazie a dio non ci deve avere a che
fare anche stavolta come non detto corri
corri corri corri aiuto lasciarla
entrare bachi tua sorella
fermi tutti posso lavare i piatti di san
pio dove colori piatti perfetto se lui
non gliene frega niente che c'è stata
gente lui lava i piatti si fa la doccia
e lava i piatti non gliene frega di
cadaveri pagliacci gente che lo butta
fuori la porta e ne frega niente
questi piatti sono un incubo eh sì
perché effettivamente il disordine in
casa la fa più paura dei nostri stessi
c'è veramente questo cessata nei
lucifero insieme che sono stessa gara
ben dentro casa
mi sta chiamando mia madre basta che
fastidio era era era un sogno devo
bisogno di una doccia ancora ma basta ma
cos'era un incubo era da un pezzo che
non mi prendevo un infarto così l'acqua
è sporca ma sto usando un sacco di
sapore la testa è questa adesso che
l'acqua sporca
allora porca vacca infame dove ho messo
le chiavi della macchina le chiavi della
ma è noi non entrò lì a tua mamma entra
lido verso le chiavi della macchina
veloce e con un quale chiavi della
macchina all'altra volta porca vacca
perché perché perché cambiano
l'ubicazione delle cose ma vuoi vedere
che le chiavi della macchina sola dentro
salve ci siamo già visti prima per
favore e non faccia scherzi dove
dovrebbe essere chiavi della macchina
non lo so li spostano ogni volta mamma
ti puzza la mamma o salve eri tu prima
che mi hai fatto venire l'infarto bene
adesso non devo più lavare i piatti ma
devo trovare le chiavi della macchina
quindi per favore non fate scherzi
chiavi della macchina chiavi della
macchina chiavi della macchina chiavi di
tua sorella
c'era anche questa uscita prima ma se la
sono inventata suscita non c'era prima
non so dove sono le chiami davanti a chi
se ne frega usciamo ma come key card e
casato ma ripensandoci non mi interessa
moltissimo andar fuori va bene così devo
fare più cose perché dovrei uscire non
lo so perché c'è stata una di là in
cucina
potrebbe essere un'idea uscire perché
c'è stata la perché c'è il libro di più
di pasqua cosa guarda ma come c'è il
libro di più di fare allo scaffale ansia
e miste chiama aiuto aiuto aiuto o merda
fatto riuscire a farvi uscire tutta sta
stanza brutta nel bagno nel bagno dove
non ecco le ho trovate via via fuggi
fuggi sciocco non ti alzare ti ammazzo
no non devi lavare i piatti di nuovo fra
te e tu hai dei problemi al cervello ti
mancano tutti i neuroni che li sei
mangiato a colazione porca vacca un file
a a lavare i piatti ma sei stupido cosa
ditemi se vi sembra normale lavare i
piatti
in una situazione del genere algedi pure
le scale grazie no le scale non si
accendeva bene sticazzi possa lavare i
piatti col mastrolindo grazie
gentilissimi adesso quando finisce di
lavare non ti non ti voltare zio non ti
voltare appena finisce di lavare non ti
voltare fermo tu corri fuori subito ma
si apre non sembra che questo bellissimo
ci risulti prego oh mio dio non si apre
più la porta
cosa devo fare qua non si accende
marchio più la luce cosa devo fare
posso andare a lavoro adesso bene e non
si apre cosa faccia elemento che porta
madonna dovrebbe essere la scatola dei
fusibili di nuovo meglio meglio metterla
a posto prima di uscire che ne so io
come si ripara la scatola dei possibili
io ho mai giocato a una roba così bassa
sono già apre le porte o se non ho mai
giocato a una roba così agghiacciante in
vita mia basta
ma tu puoi preoccuparti della scatola
dei fusibili dei piatti e di farsi la
doccia quando in casa c'è l'inferno
coriano tedesca trova un fusibile quindi
si spegne la luce si vede se con la luce
accesa no monte ci sarò va e orribile
questa roba veramente l'atroce la cosa
più brutta del gioco secondo me ora
d'aria da qualche parte sono convinto
che ci debba essere suscettibile se non
me lo chiederebbe non togliamo la luce
perché se non tipo si incazza e non è
c'era giovane porino fusibili fusi in
realtà posso trovare anche le cose
sconnesse quindi trovare fusibili dopo
lo prende un pò delli dietro stavolta
porca vacca la forchetta o gesù cristo
via via via via via via via via via via
via via via via via via via zitto tu da
lavare i piatti
se lava i piatti nessuno mi tocca perché
ovviamente tutti mi guardano lavare i
piatti
raga manca magari fusibile cioè non so
cosa dovrei fare scusatemi ma sarai
anche deficiente qua dovrebbe funzionare
tutto la bambola ancora lì le chiavi
cielo
a meno che non cada la corrente in
questo momento
ti prego ci sono ma ti pare che in
questo momento io vedo io non so neanche
dove sia su fusibile penso che è
successo la risposta è vicina ok
e questa la scatola valigia aiuto aiuto
e la madonna gatti gioco euro simac al
mio state carnage a voi siete scemi
riproviamoci nata una volta facciamo
quello che si chiama le ali for work non
posso perché manca della corrente
accaduto è bene
aridaje mor casino ma vado di nuovo qua
accendo non mi volto neanche corro
subito marcia accesa accendono già
accesa accesa aiuto è accesa la luce
cosa va
basta basta basta e soprattutto le parti
sono rotto le
mi sono rotto le palle proprio non so se
se se si è capito mi sono rotto mi sono
tre parti nei vostri disinstalla elimina
ecco però che video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come assessore di riuscire un
momento mi piace ricordatevi di lavare i
piatti perché se non al casinò sono
cinesi di vedere ci vediamo al prossimo
video continua a non trovare telecomando
ma stavo trova da cercare che palle
e buio quindi cerco dopo dai ragazzi
[Musica]